et
si tu veux je te fais un tour de magie
ouais
[Musique]
dis-moi comment tu t'appelles
taylor
[Musique]
j'ai commencé à vraiment bien aimé
rin et j'ai fait que c'est partir
[Musique]
quitter alors
tu sais comment il s'appelle
ils marchent pas
accroche
c'est préparer le petit déjeuner qu'ils
y avaient mis quoi
sel et du poivre
vous pouvez nous dire si vous avez
jusqu'à son frère il se faisait enlever
un homme avec des ballons noirs
j'avais rêvé juste
et coupe la tête que mara 18
[Musique]
n'est pas de regarder comment beaucoup
un cadeau un code tu te souviens du code
tel match
au
top
certains d'une arme
dia par finnair
mauvais chez vous
mappus une de ces trolls